Hi everyone, I'm Liv, I'm User Experience Designer on the Burp Scanner Development Team
and today I'm here to talk a little bit about the changes that we've made to the dashboard as well
as some improvements and features that we've added to. So I'll jump into a project file.
The first and most important thing to note is that we've moved the event log and all issues
into a bottom drawer. For the event log this gives you more space to view the event details
but the bottom drawer is also global so it can be accessed from anywhere in Burp.
And this meant if you wanted to check any event log items or new issues
you can open it from wherever you are rather than having to go back to the dashboard.
For all new issues you can now delete single and multiple issues and additionally and this has
been in since November but we've added the ability to filter by b-check, scan and extension generated
issues to make it easier to find what you're looking for. If any events happen or any issues
are found whilst the bottom drawer is closed you'll get notification dots based on the severity of the
issue. Jumping into the main view of the dashboard now and we've moved tasks into a menu on the left
hand side of the screen. In the left hand panel you'll see any lie tasks, scans or intruder tasks.
From here you can see the status of your task and you can also reorder and rename your tasks as well.
You can also resize the side panel to make it suit your workspace.
Moving into the detail of the task cards this has largely stayed the same as when you could pop them out.
However we've added a task summary for anything with an audit you'll see on the summary view
the most serious vulnerabilities ranked by severity and for crawl specific tasks we've displayed
what's been found and added to the sitemap. On the right hand side of any task you'll see a task
configuration in more detail and any progress when a task is running. And finally in the bottom right
hand corner we've added a task log for when a task is running this will give a bit more detail as to what the
scanner is up to when it is running. We're really hoping the changes to the dashboard will improve
your workflow so we'd love to hear if you have any thoughts or feedback. Thanks!